allemagne à nous voir sa chanson n'était
pas un homme elle décrit la lâcheté d'un
homme qui s'est frotté voilà dans le
métro alors on sait ça vous est déjà
arrivé ou pas merci merci
moi j'avais envie de faire cette chanson
parce que quand je suis sorti de cette
rame de métro je me suis dit c'est
tellement injuste
on n'a pas laissé passé raconté ça c'est
que dès qu'il ya un petit enfin le métro
il tourne un peu la main sur le säntis
nom est là qu est ce que tu fais tu
t'excuses je te dis ah excusez moi
d'avoir été dans votre chemin monsieur
et je trouve ça tellement c'est pas des
armes
c'est vraiment des ya pas de vous et des
arrivées lentilles avoué delphine toutes
deux des trois guerres auteurs n'ont pas
dit non mais vous allez pas le métro
mais vous en vous à moi ça mais moi ça
mais a beaucoup arrivent et vous arrivez
l'histoire alors j'aime beaucoup ses
paroles si vous êtes en y abat mois à
plusieurs reprises mais franchement j'ai
déjà dit le jour où j'ai arrêté de
prendre les transports en commun plus
jamais c'est un jour où j'ai pris je
voulais dit le métro le train le rer et
y avait à chaque fois dans chaque wagon
où je montais y avait quelqu'un qui se
masturbait c'est au même journée la même
journée je m'empare al amal mais pour la
grande on m'a laissé des paroles que
beaucoup de femmes vivent alors ce sont
des paroles qui ont blessé c'est énorme
et son nom mais tout le monde mais c'est
un vrai c'est c'est eh bien c'est qu'en
plus elle culpabilise et c'est en
sortant qu'elle se dit mais quand même
c'est bien normal
bon ça vous est déjà ça m'est déjà
arrivé de thouars excusez moi mais ça
m'est arrivé mais tout le temps tout le
temps
[Rires]
oui ou non mais vous c'est vrai oui tous
les sens et passait effectivement vous
faites moi dans ces cas là vous faites
quoi âmes qui vont jusqu'au bout moi je
fais comme si j'avais rien remarqué et
en partant je fais ça suffit maintenant
jamais je suis pas tous en même temps tu
as un bail tout ce qu'ils trouvent
moi ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois de
voir un homme qui se masturbait devant
moi dans le métro alors moi par contre
je crie je vais taper sur le mec avec
mon sac je m'étais mis dans un état de
j'étais complètement ça m'a rendue folle
et moi y avait un frotteur aussi
déguisés en clowns et je les croisais
plusieurs fois c'est le kia motors mais
non c'est parce que oui et le mc areavey
déguisés en clowns exercée sur toi gros
relous aussi en plus un gros relou mais
dès qu'on le voyait rond se signalait
entre copines attention le confronter on
en a parlé et il roule on en a parlé
avec vos maris ça vous ça même quand il
était petit
non si oui mais sa croix ya quelques
mois ça m'est jamais arrivé mais j'ai
une cousine qui s'est fait lécher la
joue mais non elle a été traumatisée
alors pendant l'horaire pour alors au
japon c'est au japon c'est devenu un tel
phénomène préoccupant que maintenant les
rames sont sont ne sont plus mixte
maintenant il ya les rames pour les
femmes et les hommes pour les hommes
dans le métro mais elles ne sont plus
ensemble c'est incroyable